[Musik]
Arbeitgeber wollen dass wir später in
Rente gehen Finanzminister Christian
Lindner zeigt sich angeblich offen für
ein Tempolimit und wenn es nach Markus
Söder geht dann sollen die Bayern trotz
corona-infektion arbeiten dürfen was
Corona angeht ja da hat der bayerische
Ministerpräsident wahrlich eine 180 Grad
Kehrtwende hingelegt vom
corona-maßnahmen wüter zum
freiheitlichen Revoluzzer böse Zungen
bezeichnen auch als Heuchler damit
herzlich Willkommen zu füllen meine
Gäste heute Abend sind christian
Schubert Psycho neuroimmunologe aus
Innsbruck errechnet scharf mit der
corona-politik ab nicht gefallen wird
das womöglich vielleicht ich weiß es
noch nicht den Neurobiologen Marion
Martin Korte er warnt in seinem neuen
Buch vor Corona Spätfolgen und
befürchtet in 10 bis 20 Jahren eine Flut
an alzheimer-erkrankungen für den
Ökonomen Christian Kreis sind hingegen
die grünen Politiker Harbeck und
baerbock ja man kann sagen ein Dorn im
Auge inwiefern das werden wir heute noch
erfahren auch mit von der Partie
Politikwissenschaftler und USA expert
Josef brame mehr bewertet für uns den
Ausgang der Zwischenwahlen schaff Trump
ein Comeback und was bedeutet das für
uns mich persönlich beschäftigt noch ein
wenig mehr als Trump unser
Gesundheitsminister Karl Lauterbach
mittlerweile wird wohl jeder von ihnen
die Impfkampagne von Lauterbach kennen
falls nicht hören wir doch einmal rein
ich schütze mich weil ich lieber mit
meinen Enkelkindern Spiele als mit
meiner Gesundheit es schütze mich weil
ich in Quarantäne keiner Leben retten
kann ich schütze mich weil Düfte für
mich das schönste
ja das waren jetzt drei von 80
Protagonisten die berichten warum sie
sich gegen Corona impfen lassen die
Währung der Kampagne sie haben schon
gemerkt das sind Emotionen doch wenn es
eines während der corona-pandemie meiner
Meinung nach genug gab dann waren das ja
genau Emotionen was uns ja fehlt sind
Fakten mich stört auch allein schon der
Slogan der Kampagne ich schütze mich
wenn die Impfung also auf Selbstschutz
abzieht warum wurden die Menschen die
sich gegen die Impfung entschieden haben
dann vergangenen Winter ausgegrenzt sie
merken schon ich habe bei dem Thema
ordentlich Temperatur wenn ich mich
wirklich mittlerweile Frage was das
eigentlich soll gefährden die Menschen
ohne corona-impfung ihre Mitmenschen
jetzt also nicht für mich ist diese
Impfkampagne ein Skandal ich finde
Gesundheitsminister Karl Lauterbach
sollte die Gelder endlich nutzen um die
corona-pandemie aufzuarbeiten und meine
erste Frage geht an Herrn Schubert der
Staat gibt ja für diese Kampagne 800
Millionen aus ist es aus ihrer Sicht gut
angelegtes Geld
es war bis dato kein gutes angelegtes
Geld in den letzten drei Jahren und es
wird auch weiterhin nicht so sein und es
wird auch in Zukunft nicht so sein ich
bin zutiefst überzeugt wir haben eine
Pandemie nicht eines Coronavirus sondern
wir haben eine Pandemien des falschen
Menschenbildes in einer schlechten
Wissenschaft und
wenn ich auch in der Vorbereitung auf
diese Sendung sollte uns ja auch ein
Statement überlegen und und ich bin
dafür über ein Zitat gestolpert bei den
Schließungen der Kitas in der
corona-pandemie haben wir uns geirrt
also es wird jetzt ein Irrtum zugegeben
von Karl Lauterbach und da denke ich mir
aha also 3 Millionen Kinder Kleinkinder
sind irrtümlicherweise an ihrer
Entwicklung gehemmt worden
bei ihrem Thema ihre Argumentation ich
bin schon sehr gespannt darauf freue ich
mich einmal noch ich freue mich auch
noch um einmal noch bei der Impfung zu
bleiben
wie sieht das denn jetzt aus mit dem
fremdschutz und dem Selbstschutz weil
ich finde die Rhetorik aus der jetzigen
Kampagne ich schütze mich ist ja eine
ganz andere als die die letzten Winter
angebracht wurde weswegen ja Menschen
ausgegrenzt werden weil wenn man sich
nur selbst schützen kann wie es die
Kampagne ja suggeriert warum wurden
Menschen ausgegrenzt
das ist ein ist es ein ideologisches
Problem diese corona-pandemie und da ist
irrsinnig viel irrational und es werden
lügende sehr gesagt es werden Menschen
in Angst und Panik versetzt es ist man
kann mit gar nicht mehr richtig
diskutieren auch auf wissenschaftlicher
empirischer Ebene
das Zeug wirkt nicht ja und und es wurde
gelogen und es wurden falsche Tatsachen
vorgespielt um das offensichtlich unter
die Bevölkerung zu bringen aus welchen
Grund auch immer das unter die
Bevölkerung gebracht werden sollte aber
ich bin ein ein großer Gegner davon
Impfstoffe initionsstoffe Messenger
rna-impfungen Menschen in diesem großen
Stil zu verabreichen vor allem jenen
denen man es nicht verabreichen muss
weil sie von kovid kaum betroffen sind
wir wissen genau welche Risikogruppen es
sind das sind sehr alte Menschen sind
sie aber schon für die Impfung ich denke
wenn jemand in eine Risikogruppe
reingekommen ist dann wird es
wahrscheinlich das klingt jetzt zynisch
auch schon egal sein aber eine
messengeren Alien von kriegt einer
schwerstes Diabetes hat und Herz dann
muss man wahrscheinlich irgendetwas tun
und wenn die Menschen meinen sie sollen
sie werden sich dann impfen dann sollen
sie das tun und vielleicht wirkt da auch
Placebo ein Stück weit mit da habe ich
überhaupt kein Thema damit aber Menschen
die gesund sind ja in solche im und
Kinder vor allem ja und mittlerweile
auch Schwangere es wird ja
offensichtlich auch empfohlen Schwangere
zu impfen das ist ein Verbrechen aus
fertig Schluss und wenn ich da über
irgendwelche Gelder reden soll dann dann
geht es einfach weiter mit dem
Verbrechen für mich ist es eine
Katastrophe es ist ein Desaster harter
Vorwurf ein Verbrechen
frage ich gerne Herrn Korte einmal
würden sie da mitgehen wie würden sie
das einstufen mich etwas gewundert ist
eine schwierige Problematik aber hier zu
hören wo es so klare Evidenzen gibt was
die Impfung bringt auch für Kinder auch
für Schwangere die einen deutlich
höheres Risiko einer Fehlgeburt haben
wenn sie nicht geimpft sind und an COBIT
19 erkranken da wundere ich mich ein
bisschen das gerade gerade gehört gerade
gehört zu haben dazu gibt es Daten dazu
gibt es Untersuchungen und das jetzt
einfach weg zu wischen und so zu tun
dass man Menschen all diesen
Gefährdungen aussetzt gerade jungen
Müttern gerade den werdenden Kindern das
finde ich schon eigentümlich also
Schubert ist offensichtlich in der Lage
zu lesen und wissenschaftliche Literatur
zu lesen das dann zu ignorieren und
abzutun als Propaganda das finde ich
schon sehr fahrlässig also da bin ich
anderer Meinung was aber ja sicher
stimmt ist dass wir gesehen haben dass
diese Impfung kein schwarz-weiß Spiel
ist es schützt einen nicht zu 100%
selber auch das stimmt es schützt doch
nicht zu 100% andere Menschen es ist
sogar so dass drei Monate nach der
Impfung man sogar ein relativ hohes
Risiko hat sich selber noch zu
infizieren und andere Menschen zu
infizieren und es hat sich auch gezeigt
dass ja die Länder in ganz
unterschiedlich auf der Welt mit der
Pandemie umgegangen sind zum Beispiel
gab es in Japan deutlich weniger
lockdowns aber auch deutlich weniger
Tote also man sieht sag mal und long the
line
Schubert immer betont hat das es gibt
nicht eben eine Maßnahme Menschen zu
schützen sondern in gefahren wurde eben
viel an den eigenen an die
Eigenverantwortung der Menschen
appelliert es wurden viele Masken
getragen es wurden Risikosituationen
gemieden die Impfquote war hervorragend
auch das hat natürlich die Bevölkerung
geschützt aber es gab viel weniger
lockdowns und insbesondere Kindern
gegenüber wurde anders umgegangen bei
uns konnten und mussten eher Kinder zu
Hause bleiben als Arbeitnehmer von zu
Hause aus zu arbeiten das sieht man wie
bei uns die Prioritäten waren und für
einen sechsjähriges Kind ein Jahr nicht
mit anderen zusammengespielt zu haben
heißt 6 seines
lebenskampagne die wir eben gesehen
haben
Impfkampagnen sind immer riesige
Reduzierungen von komplexen
Problematiken in einzelnen Sätzen da tue
ich mich auch schwer weil man eben dazu
einlädt zu widersprechen wenn man so tut
als wenn nur eine Impfung einen schützen
kann dabei muss man sagen im Moment wenn
Leute dreimal geimpft sind und unter 60
wäre das Tragen einer Maske deutlich
wichtiger als sich impfen zu lassen denn
der Impfung ist eine Medikament
Medikament hat eine Wirkung es hat aber
auch eine Nebenwirkung es haben alle
Medikamente und das gehört zur Impfung
auch dazu
einfach erklärt in so kurzen ich weiß
nicht ob man es anders machen kann würde
ich ich würde mir ich würde mir also ich
würde mir keine Werbung anschauen von
einem einem Professor wie mir der für 15
Minuten differenziert erklärt wie die
Situation ist hier hat man einzelne
Leute mit Einzelmeinungen gezeigt das
scheint mir zunächst mal legitim zu sein
und das was gesagt wurde war auch
richtig kann das von meinen Eltern auch
sagen die haben sich jetzt die vierte
Mal impfen lassen die sind eben auch 88
85 die haben das auch gemacht weil sie
dann freier geben und ohne Angst mit
ihren Kindern Enkeln umgehen können also
da war das Argument schon sehr ähnlich
insofern finde ich das nicht verfehlt
wir hören mal weiter hier in der Runde
Herr Kreis wie sehen Sie denn die
Impfkampagne hat sie das jetzt überzeugt
die drei Clips mich hätte es nicht
überzeugt im Ausland ist in einigen
Ländern Impfung unter 18 mittlerweile
verboten darf nur noch auf aktives
Anraten der Ärzte überhaupt geimpft
werden die impfen Nebenwirkungen zeigen
sich als erheblich auch die Schäden dazu
werden wenig erfasst
michel hat es nicht überzeugt und die
ganzen Versprechungen die früher gemacht
worden sind ist schützt deinen Opa ich
schützt deine Mama haben sich im
Nachhinein als Lügen erwiesen es schützt
nicht andere schützt ausschließlich ein
selbst die ganze Kampagne die damals
gelaufen ist stellt sich im Nachhinein
als Lüge heraus und die Menschen die das
damals kritisiert haben die werden heute
immer noch als querdenke rechtsoffen
diffamiert ist eine ungeheuer
Möglichkeit die Menschen die damals
diese
absolut nicht evidenzbasierten Dinge in
die Welt gesetzt nicht wissenschaftlich
wie uns Herr Lauterbach heute immer noch
absolut nicht evidenzbasiert nicht
wissenschaftlich die Menschen dürfen es
immer noch sagen und die die damals des
kritisiert haben moment mal wir müssen
erstmal abwägen great Barrington
declaration also grandiose
wissenschaftliche gesagt haben falsch
die werden halt immer noch diffamiert
also ich bin fassungslos vor allem ging
es auch um die Frage wie man das Geld
verwenden wollen sollte sollte mal für
Aufarbeitung verwenden ich bin sehr
dankbar für Herrn Söder ich finde es ein
Wende großartig kann es nicht
nachvollziehen aber es zeigte dass man
auch die die Meinung ändern kann aber da
mal nachzufassen wer hat wann was gesagt
und erlaufen Videos von Menschen die
dann gesagt haben wer sich nicht impfen
lässt es ist sind Verbrecher und mit
Nazi-Vergleiche Republik surf sie zeigen
mit dem Finger Nikolaus
diese Frau ist nicht vom Amtsgericht
verklagt worden obwohl sie absolut
rassistisch waren eingeklagen hat und
andere Menschen die
kritisch waren gegen die laufen
Strafverfahren da ist eine
Ungleichbehandlung eine Heuchelei in der
Politik bis heute das finde ich
unsäglich ich glaube diese Impfkampagne
kein bisschen Herr brame sie dürfen auch
bewerten benoten hat sie die
Impfkampagne abgeholt
und ich bin hier fein raus ich bin nur
ein Doktor wenn deutscher Professor muss
er zu allem was sagen können
aber wenn deutsche Professor muss zu
allem was sagen können und ich brauche
das jetzt nicht die spreche jetzt als
privatpersonal ich habe hier keine
Expertise aber ich habe für mich
entschieden ich lasse mich impfen ich
bin zweimal geimpft gepustet zweimal
gelesen also Beispiel dafür dass man
trotzdem es kriegen kann aber ich glaube
dass der Verlauf milder ist und ich
glaube wir haben Daten dafür dass es
deutlich und die die an long Corvette
leiden vor allem in Amerika werden
irgendwann ein riesen ökonomisches und
auch soziales Problem werden da gibt's
jetzt Vorzeit Studien schon die würde
ich sagen angesprochen also jetzt nicht
der Impfstatus hat die Kampagne sie
angesprochen als Bürger abgeholt würden
Sie sagen yes we can nach der Kampagne
ja manchmal muss ja da genau wie
Fernsehen nicht immer nur für für
spezifische Leute gemacht ist so viel
wie möglich ich glaube das wird schon
Leute ansprechen ich bin jetzt
wahrscheinlich nicht die Hauptzielgruppe
ich habe mich ja schon impfen lassen ich
glaube es geht jetzt um die vielleicht
Sie drei oder sie zwei die sich noch
nicht dämpfen lassen haben sie sollen
angesprochen werden aber es funktioniert
offensichtlich nicht wie ich hier höre
ich habe meinen Impfstatus ja gar nicht
bekannt gegeben mache ich auch nicht
mehr weil ich das falsch finde ist eine
freie persönliche Entscheidung aber ist
gut wir haben ja heute ein Diplomaten in
der Runde das gefällt mir gut jetzt
kommen wir zweimal nicht zu diplomatisch
ist wir sprechen über die
Kollateralschäden genau und und ich habe
ja gleich mein anfangsstatement hier
ziemlich emotional vorgebracht und und
Herr kort hat gleich reagiert aber ich
denke das Problem dass wir haben Herr
kortis dass wir zwei verschiedene
wissenschaftsauffassungen haben ich
glaube wir können das mal auf den Tisch
bringen zwei verschiedene Menschenbilder
ganz offensichtlich ja ich habe auch
diese ganze Zeit begleitet mit mit einer
kritischen Haltung der Medizin gegenüber
und habe dabei möglicherweise auch Dinge
gesehen die vielleicht andere nicht
sehen ja
tatsache ist wenn ich sage verschiedenes
unterschiedliches wissenschaftsbild oder
Menschenbild
das was ich jetzt in den letzten drei
Jahren gesehen habe und zwar von Beginn
an war eine eine ganz offensichtliche
Ausgrenzung des psychischen und des
sozialen aus Menschenbild ganz klar und
da und darunterkrankt die Schulmedizin
seit Jahrhunderten das ist kein neues
Phänomen wir sprechen in der
Wissenschaftstheorie von Dualismus und
von Reduktionismus Dualismus meint wir
grenzen Geist Ziele und Körper ab wir
trennen sie voneinander genau das haben
wir gesehen in den letzten drei Jahren
massivst ich habe von Beginn an ich kann
mich noch erinnern April 2020 in der
Tiroler Tageszeitung einen kleinen
Bericht darüber geschrieben mir war
sofort klar hier stimmt was nicht hier
wird was Wesentliches ausgegrenzt in den
Lockdown machen oder Schulschließungen
machen nämlich das Wesentliche das uns
Menschen ausmacht wie ich weiß es aus
der psychonomologie ich bin Forscher ich
beschäftige wieder Verbindung Psycho und
Immunsystem ich weiß wie übermächtig
psychisches und soziales ist wenn es
umso Immunsystem geht und wenn wir
Menschen auseinander bringen dann ist
das eine ganz lineare ganz kühle
Rechnung wir denken es sind Maschinen
aber es sind keine Maschinen sind
Menschen und wir Menschen auseinander
bringen dann kriegen den
Immunsuppression dann haben die in
sozialen Schaden und diese soziale
Schaden ist für meine Begriffe und da
haben wir einen unterschiedliches Bild
wahrscheinlich für meine Begriffe weit
gefährlich als das Virus und es hat ja
auch gezeigt dass es Virus so gefährlich
nicht ist es betrifft da ich bin kein
Corona Leugner ich mag den Namen schon
gar nicht aber ich sehe den Ernst der
Lage überhaupt keine Frage bitte für
eine ganz begrenzte kleine Gruppe eine
riesige Gruppe die geschützt gehört wo
dieses viele Geld an Impfkampagnen das
jetzt ausgegeben wird längst hätte
verwendet werden müssen in den Maßnahmen
jetzt wird es schon wieder verpulvert
jetzt müsste man sich vielleicht um long
kovid kümmern auch da ein interessantes
Thema weil da bin ich auch absolut
anderer Meinung wie Herr Korte also das
heißt wir haben es mit einem riesen
Schaden und Medizin Desaster zu tun weil
wir psychisches und soziales weggesteckt
haben oder weggespalten haben von
Menschen und ein eine Katastrophe
angerichtet haben und wenn es zynisch
klingt auf der anderen Seite bin ich
auch froh darüber denn jetzt kann sich
was verändern jetzt wird aufgearbeitet
und zwar jetzt wird aufgearbeitet und
dieses Verantwortlichen ich bin davon
überzeugt die müssen auch die
Verantwortung tragen und das wird auch
vor Gericht sein der Fragen doch direkt
einmal Herr Korte fanden sie denn
überhaupt die Schulschließungen richtig
wenn ich Sie richtig verstanden habe
fanden sie dir auch nicht richtig
nur weil ich wissenschaftlichen Daten
viel Gewicht einräume dass ich ein
anderes Menschenbild habe ich bin
Neurowissenschaftler der sich durchaus
mit den Effekten die die Umwelt die
Menschen auf die Psyche haben auf unser
Lernvermögen sogar auch auf das
Alzheimer Risiko ist einer meiner
Forschungsgebiete unter zeigt sich dass
eines der Risikofaktoren davon
Einsamkeit ist das haben wir gerade zu
Lockdown Zeiten enorm praktiziert und
auch da war ich immer kritisch nicht
gegen die lockdown-maßnahmen weil ich
auch gesehen habe man muss unterscheiden
ob einen Virus einem bestimmten
Maßnahmen aufzwingt die man für richtig
hält und wie man die dann durchzieht
also zum Beispiel bei den
Schulschließungen habe ich mich von
Anfang an kritisch geäuß weil ich gesagt
habe wir müssen hier abwägen gegen das
individuelle Risiko was die Kinder haben
was tatsächlich was ein schwerer
Verläufe angeht niedrig ist auch nicht
Null aber niedrig und die durften nicht
weiter zur Schule gehen und genau mit
den Konsequenzen die wir gerade gehört
haben da haben pubertierende ihre
Pubertät verpasst wir haben noch
kleinere Kinder die die hier ihre
sozialen Umfeldes beraubt wurden und das
muss man jetzt im Nachhinein auch
tatsächlich haben wir auch gerade gehört
kritisch auch aber angeht hat Herr
Lauterbach ja auch schon zugegeben dass
das unnötig war also dass die
kita-schließungen die Frage ist ob man
das damals hätte wissen können man hat
ja auch Leute die da arbeiten die älter
sind die durchaus ein Risiko haben und
es ist auch nicht eine kleine Gruppe wir
haben allein ab fast zwei Millionen
Krebspatienten in Deutschland die alle
in Risiko darstellen wir haben in
Kindergärten auch ältere
Kindergärtnerinnen die eben zum Teil
auch Diabetes haben also das ist schon
so ganz einfach ist die Entscheidung
auch nicht aber ich habe von Anfang an
mich dafür stark gemacht dass man die
Kinder
sein lässt und versucht das einigermaßen
einzudämmen zum Beispiel Schulen mit
Maske hat sich gezeigt klappt eigentlich
relativ gut gibt auch Infektionen aber
alle können sich relativ gut schützen
man war nicht bereit wenn man über Geld
redet wofür man Geld ausgibt und man
nicht bereit Lüftungen dort zu
installieren die Geld gekostet hätten
wenn ich mir gucke wie viel in
verschiedene Maßnahmen zum Kauf von
Lufthansa und sonst was aufgewendet
wurden aber 5 Euro 50 in die Schule zu
stecken das geht nicht bleiben wir noch
einmal bei der These von Herr Schubert
also die kita-schließung haben nichts
gebracht die Schulschließungen haben
auch nichts gebracht also Stand der
Forschung die kitasschließung auf jeden
Fall nicht jetzt gerade wurde gesagt die
Masken in den Schulunterricht auch
nichts gebracht wir haben es von Beginn
angesehen das Schweden an einer Weg
gegangen ist ich möchte dass das immer
wieder betont wird wir haben ein
natürliches Experiment ein soziales
Experiment ist die Schweden durchgeführt
haben und sie waren erfolgreich aber es
wird immer unter den Tisch gekehrt so
wie diese Daten immer unter Tisch
gekehrt werden die offensichtlich gegen
dieses narrativ von einem killer-virus
das nur mit Impfung beseitigt werden
kann ja und Herr Korte sie haben
trotzdem vorhin gesagt auch Kinder
sollen geimpft werden und auch erwarten
und und junge Erwachsene Kinder sind von
covid nicht betroffen
0,5 betroffen also Entschuldigung wie
denn jetzt sagen Sie das doch bitte mal
von Virus gibt das pin-syndrom es gibt
schwere grippale Effekte es gibt
Entzündungen im Gehirn es gibt
herzkranzentzündungen auch bei auch bei
Kindern die kann man nicht
wegdiskutieren da kann man nicht so tun
als wenn Kindern nichts passieren kann
das wäre so als würde ich sagen die
brauchen die brauchen sich morgen ich
hoffe sich die brauchen sich morgen
nicht mehr anschnallen weil es gibt auch
nicht viele Kinder in Deutschland die
dann halt durch einen Unfall sterben ich
also ich meine das ist einfach eine
Risikowahrnehmung die so nicht ganz
stimmt was sie ja glaubt glaube ich
eigentlich sagen wollen ist dass man die
gefahren dort deutlich übertrieben hat
und das hat sich tatsächlich auch
bewahrheitet wissen Sie was man getan
hat man hat
während man die Politik die Schulmedizin
und die Medien
die die verantwortlich sind in diesen
letzten Jahren die haben die Kinder in
die Tonne gehauen psychosozial wir haben
sie terrorisiert tyrannisiert und dann
wundern wir uns dass sie solche
Krankheiten haben ich sage Ihnen als
Psycho normologen sie können mit
psychischen und sozialen Belastungen
alles in entzündungsphänomen machen
alles passieren im Buch beschreiben kann
alles posttraumatisch
Belastungsstörungen sein das wissen Sie
ganz genau was sie aber nicht
berücksichtigen ist dass man natürlich
in all diesen Untersuchungen
Kontrollgruppen hatte die unter den
gleichen psychosozialen Bedingungen
aufgewachsen sind und die andere
Phänomene zeigen ich wundere mich dass
sie das Kontrollieren man hat ja nicht
ohne Kontrollen gemessen insofern ist
das immer zwischen Faktoren genau die
psychischen Faktoren sind würden
Lockdown gleich ob sie sich infiziert
haben oder nicht und viele gerade bei
longkowith haben einen leichten Verlauf
gehabt die waren nicht schwer krank wie
sieht es gerade auch angedeutet hat man
die Angst erfasst in diesen Studien also
ich hätte das auch gelesen man hat auch
die Angst an Seite des order gehört
Meter zu und zeigt sich im übrigen auch
entlang ihrer These auch bei den
Menschen die sich nicht infiziert haben
also auch da sieht man dass die Pandemie
stärker zu Angstsymptomen geführt hat
die Depression hochgefahren hat und
andere psychiatrische erstörung
hervorgerufen hat auch ohne Infektion
aus meiner Sicht ein Post
pandemic-syndrom bei den Kindern wird
kennen das ja mittlerweile wenn ich das
ist kein Post aber Corona man Vielfaches
erhöht wenn man halt einmal infiziert
waren also jetzt den Menschen die schwer
krank sind an longkow wird abzusprechen
dass sie krank sind oder dass sie nur
automatische Störungen
Psychosomatik ab ich werde das nicht ab
sondern ich sage man kann das nicht auf
ein Phänomen reduzieren natürlich werde
ich keine Psychosomatik als
Neurowissenschaftler abwertend weil ich
weiß wie das Gehirn auch soziale Signale
interpretieren kann sie haben das eben
mal selber gesagt wie Signale aus der
Umwelt auch dass sie Immunsystem so
Premieren also unterdrücken können auch
das ist mir bekannt darüber forsche ich
im übrigen auch also dass mein
Forschungsgebiet damit das bei ihnen
einsickert das heißt darüber ist aus und
psychologischen Mitteln
wenn ich einmal einen gemeinsamen Nenner
von Ihnen beiden herauskristallisieren
darf dann haben sie ja auch gesagt die
kita-schließungen waren rückblickend ob
man das jetzt bessere wissen können oder
nicht falsch sie sagen auch die
kita-schließung waren falsch den
gemeinsamen Nenner hier dann ist jetzt
meine Frage wen könnte und sollte man
denn dafür verantwortlich machen Herr
Schubert weil das ist ja hier so
anscheinend noch zu betonen wenn wir
sagen dass die kita-schließungen falsch
waren und die Schulschließungen falsch
waren dann ist das nicht ein
Kavaliersdelikt dann ist das nicht
irgendetwas ach dann haben wir das getan
und es war wohl ein Fehler absolut
sondern wir haben hier dass die
Gesundheit von Kindern langfristig über
Jahrzehnte gefährdet das ist ein ganz
wichtiger Punkt wir wissen aus der
psychology dass wenn sie Kinder in so
eine Situation bringen und ihr sie an
Entwicklungsstörungen in
Entwicklungsstörung bringen und wir
wissen ja nicht mal was da passiert
konkret Lebenszeit die verlieren konkret
Lebenszeit das heißt die sterben früher
wie viele Jahre oder kann man das gar
nicht vorstellen das kann man sagen es
gibt Studien die zeigen wenn wenn Kinder
im ersten oder mit Kinder und
Jugendlichen ersten 18 Lebensjahren
sechs und mehr schwere Belastungen
mitgemacht haben in ihrem Leben dann
haben sie ein lebenszeitverlust von etwa
20 Jahren das ist ganz schön viel also
wir reden hier von wirklich ganz was
Wichtigem und wenn sie sagen wer soll
hier oder wie soll das zur Verantwortung
gezogen werden ja es wird aufgearbeitet
so wie immer diese Dinge aufgearbeitet
werden müssen solche Traumatisierungen
die mit der Gesellschaft stattgefunden
haben und es sind ja nicht nur die
Kinder wir reden jetzt in diesem Fall
von den Kindern wir haben die
Jugendlichen natürlich wir haben genau
hier Korte das auch noch mal gesagt hat
es ist hier etwas passiert das kann man
nicht einfach sagen jetzt gehen wir zu
einer zur Normalität wieder über das
geht nicht dass das da werde ich mich
auch absoluter gegen wehren es ist noch
mal um es klarzustellen Reduktionismus
und Dualismus in der Schulmedizin und
die Untersuchung von denen sie reden ich
bin überrascht dass Sie auch
psychologische Forschung betreiben bei
sich in Braunschweig dass Interviews
gehen dass sie Fragebögen austeilen dass
sie neurobiologisch forschen mit
psychischen
Methoden das ist mir jetzt neu und dann
habe ich Ihnen vielleicht Unrecht getan
wenn Sie das tun ich frage ja auch
einmal den Ökonomen in der Runde weil
Corona hat hier auch ein
gesamtwirtschaftlichen Schaden muss das
auch aufgearbeitet werden unbedingt noch
eine Bemerkung zu Herrn Korte
laut Studien der Deutschen Gesellschaft
für Kinder und Jugendmedizin ist das
Risiko zu ertrinken 5 oder 10 mal größer
in Deutschland als an cobis zu sterben
also diese Infektionszahlen bei Kindern
und Jugendlichen das sind so niedrig
dass er davon eine Gefahr zu sprechen
für Kinder und Jugendliche ist ab
evidenzbiert wissenschaftlich absolut
nicht haltbar ich habe zwei Bücher
zugekaufte Wissenschaft geschrieben und
das ist ganz massiv auf Fake
Wissenschaft basiert gewesen das ist
aber das ist ein anderes Thema
ist eine Studie veröffentlicht hat die
hane Büchen war
genau ihr Fachgebiet also die lockdowns
haben unsere Wirtschaft dramatisch
geschädigt und haben dafür im Gegenzug
die Profite der großen Konzerne
dramatisch steigen lassen jeder Tag
Lockdown mein Milliardengeschäft für die
großen Konzerne und die dahinter stehen
Milliardäre ich war Investmentbanker
sieben Jahre das war ein mega geil
inwiefern ums praktisch erklärbar zu
machen inwiefern war ein Tag Lockdown
ein Geschenk für Konzerne ein Geschenk
des Himmels ja aber das Himmels war weiß
ich nicht oder aber hier im Berlin
Einzelhandel wird stillgelegt und Amazon
Jeff bestes wird zum reichsten Mann der
Welt und das gilt aber nicht nur für den
Einzelhandel nicht nur für Amazon auch
die die kleinen Gastronomen die kleinen
Hoteliers die werden getreten die großen
Ketten werden überlegen überleben das
zeigt schon Klaus Schwab sagte schon in
seinem Buch voraus es war ein massives
Interesse eigentlich der große Teil der
große Industrie lockt dann zu hart so
schlimm solange wie irgend möglich jeder
Tag war ein Milliarden Geschenk sie
sehen das an den gewinnsprüngen der
US-Konzerne die sind in den Himmel
geschafft beispielsweise nehmen wir mal
Deutschland er wird wahrscheinlich nicht
gewesen sein dass jeder Tag Lockdown
hurra war unser rückreiz sind ja nicht
die Konzerne sondern die
mittelständischen Unternehmen die
Familienunternehmen wir leben von den
Hidden Champions in diesem Land die
haben definitiv darunter gelitten wir
haben ja kein Amazon hier oder Facebook
oder die Konzerne wir haben auch große
und kleine bei der die HOGA in
Oberbayern deutsches Hotel und
Gaststätten gewährwerk mit Gastronom
erzählt man die Großgastronomie
schweinebrottenkiste am mai die
bormillionen Umsatzrückgang das macht
uns gar nichts super weil dann werden
die ganzen kleinen grautere die genaue
pleite und dann kriegen wir die
Locations kostenlos also auch in
Oberbayern die großen fressen die
kleinen und das war nicht die
Weltkonzerne die großen fressen die
kleinen auf allen Ebenen die großen
Konzerne fressen im Mittelstand diese
lockdowns war ein Frontalangriff auf
unsere Mittelstand auf die
selbstständigungsbahn eine einzige
Katastrophe und wir waren auch massive
Interessen dahinter je mehr Lockdown
umso besser umso mehr können wir die
kleinen fertig machen
wie blicken sie wirtschaftlich auf die
Lage ja ich würde sagen wenn wir die
wirtschaftsmittel dieser vielen
Milliarden nicht gehabt hätten dann wäre
der wirtschaftsgau der vielleicht jetzt
die nächsten Wochen Monate folgt
vielleicht früher gekommen wir haben ja
seit dem GAU 2728 ich glaube das müssen
sie sehr gut das ganze nur aufgeschoben
also die Notenbanken haben Geld gedruckt
das gibt es kein Morgen und irgendwann
wird es dann mal ja runtergekommen jetzt
hatten wir Corona Corona haben wir
übrigens auch Trump zu verdanken also
nicht alles war gut
und und vor allem auch oder oder
vielleicht was positives
korrigieren umgekehrt Beine nicht
gewonnen weil Trump eben auch viel
gemacht hat ich glaube der hat ein paar
Millionen mehr Amerikaner auf dem
Gewissen durch die Art und Weise wie er
umverantwortlich umgegangen ist und es
hat beiden auch geholfen weil aus dem
Keller heraus einfach den Wahlkampf
machen konnte er wäre nicht mehr
physisch in der Lage gewesen diesen
harten Wahlkampf durchzustehen also
meine These ist ohne Corona wäre Trump
ein zweites Mal ins Weiße Haus gekommen
also das ist eine aber das andere um die
These noch mal weiter zu spinnen wir
haben das sehr viel Geld gedruckt und
haben da wirklich ja jetzt noch mal in
der Finanzkrise und haben jetzt noch mal
ein stimmlos draufgelegt und draufgelegt
so und jetzt holt uns aber das ganze ein
weil wir nämlich durch Corona auch Güter
runter genommen haben auf der einen
Seite pushen wir viel Geld rein und
Drogen Geld und durch Corona wurde
wurden die Wertschöpfungsketten
zertrennt also weniger Güter und durch
dickhubbling was von Trump und da kann
man dann schon ein bisschen in das Thema
was ich dann mache wir müssen noch
rund und vielleicht hilft es dann auch
dass das auf den Punkt zu bringen also
durch dieses decubbling wurden noch mehr
Güter Weg gemacht und jetzt sind alle
überrascht alle Notenbanker das war man
viel Geld reinpusht und Güte rausnimmt
dass wir Inflation haben und die
Inflation kann man nur noch begrenzen
indem wir bremsen die Wirtschaft
abwürgen also und stehen knallharte
meinen sie die Trennung von
Wertschöpfung genau dass man sich eben
von China
wegtrennt nur noch mit guten Handeln
treibt und da werden wir noch das ein
oder andere erleben wollte auch noch
reden aber über gesundheitliche Schäden
und auch langfristige Folgen darüber
sprechen sie heute Abend ja auch in
ihrer These
genau es geht in der These darum dass
durch entzündliche Prozesse im Gehirn
die nach einer covid 19 Infektion noch
auftreten können eben auch man sieht
dass Menschen unter gehirnnebel leiden
können dass sie ein fatig-syndrom
bekommen können das heißt antriebslos
werden
eine riesige Schläfrigkeit mit sich
rumtragen die auch durch längere Pausen
nicht verbessert wird sind kurzatmig
haben häufiger Schmerzen und eins der
Probleme die diese entzündlichen
Prozesse im Gehirn mit sich bringen ist
dass auch langfristig das ein
Risikofaktor dafür ist an Alzheimer zu
erkranken im übrigen auch das haben wir
eben mal kurz angesprochen auch
ungewollte Einsamkeit ist hier ein
Risiko sich weniger zu bewegen ist ein
weiteres Risiko aber eben entzündliche
Prozesse im Gehirn sind auch ein Risiko
und auch wenn die Chance an long kovic
zu erkranken niedrig ist also die
meisten Studien finden hier fünf bis
zehn Prozent aller infizierten das heißt
aber auch dass 9 von 10 etwas nicht
bekommen insofern geht es mir nicht
darum die Panik zu machen jetzt zu sagen
jetzt müssen wir die nächste Krise
sozusagen im Gesundheitssystem erwarten
aber wir müssen aufpassen wir haben
schon jetzt riesige Ausfälle in
Krankenhäusern auch in anderen
infrastruktureinheiten durch Menschen
die in ihrem Konzentrationsvermögen in
ihrem
gedächtnisfähigkeiten eingeschränkt sind
zumindest für viele Monate und diese
Patienten muss man ernst nehmen und auch
da bin ich dabei was Herr Schubert eben
gesagt hat wir müssen über unseren
Medizinsystem nachdenken dass wir hier
in dem Sinne ganzheitlicher behandeln
müssen ist wir brauchen Teams von Ärzten
die halt diese verschiedenen Symptome
behandeln es reicht nicht dass wir den
Spezialisten für einen Organ haben weil
dann haben wir bei Krankheiten die was
mit Autoimmunität zu tun haben die
psychische Faktoren betreffen die nicht
eindeutig identifizierbar an einem
klassischen Fach der Medizin fest zu
machen sind ein ein Problem hier müssen
von der Ausbildung anders mit den
Medizin jungen Medizinern umgehen und
vor allen Dingen müssen wir glaube ich
jetzt lernen den Patienten auch als
mündigen Bürger zu betrachten den ganz
viele der Patienten vor allen Dingen
Patientinnen zwei Drittel davon sind
Frauen wurden wieder abgewiesen und
gesagt ja ja sie haben jetzt so ein
bisschen über Angststörung das kriegen
wir schon wieder in Griff und man hat
nicht die Symptome ernst genommen weil
man nicht den eindeutigen auf einem
Teststreifen feststellen machen
Biomarker hatte und ich glaube auch das
müssen wir ändern wir müssen hier die
Patienten Patientin ernster nehmen wie
kann long Kove zweifelsfrei heute
festgestellt werden zweifelsfrei kann es
nicht festgestellt werden weil ein Teil
der Symptome eben auch wir haben es eben
mal gehört können auch
Begleiterscheinungen von Einsamkeit sein
können Begleiterscheinungen vom
mangelnder Bewegung sein können
begleitentscheinungen von Stress sein
bei den Patienten wo man hat nachschauen
können hat man festgestellt dass
bestimmte Faktoren also eins ist ein
Stressfaktor der aber nicht nach oben
sondern nach unten geht dass das
Cortisol das war ganz überraschend das
zeigt dass das keine reine
Stressreaktion ist und es gibt bestimmte
Signalmoleküle des Immunsystems die
haben unseren fachnamen Interleukine da
kann man dann immer so einen eigenen
Sprachkurs machen entscheiden das ist
ein Signalstoff der das Immunsystem
antreibt und da hat man gefunden dass
bei den Patienten wo man hat
nachgeschaut dass erhöht ist aber es
fehlen jetzt große klinische Studien um
hier das Spektrum etwas genauer
abzudecken es wäre aber für die
Patienten ganz ganz wichtig ich meine
die haben ihre Symptome auch ohne
Biomarker deren Marker ist ihre
kognitive Eingeschränktheit ihre
schnelle Schlappheit aber es würde
helfen eine Behandlung
es fehlt an Daten und an Studien die
eben jetzt auch sagen wie wie kann ich
helfen wann mache ich welche behandeln
das ist ganz unterschiedlich die mache
ich eine kognitive Therapie mache ich
eine Physiotherapie bei Menschen mit
einem fatig-syndrom bin ich ganz
vorsichtig weil wenn man die kurzfristig
überlastet erleben die einen riesigen
Rückfall haben Menschen sich eine
Kurzatmigkeit angewöhnt das ist jetzt
gar nicht dass der Virus noch da ist der
Virus was gemacht sondern war mit der
Atmung vorsichtiger und hat nicht tief
genug ins Zwerchfell eingeatmet die
brauchen Atemtraining da gibt es auch
welche die genug Geld haben haben sie
von Opernsängern trainieren lassen das
muss man nicht sondern man kann ganz
normale Atemübungen machen es gibt auch
Menschen die unter geruchsverlust leiden
da kann man geruchstraining machen es
gibt viele verschiedene mögliche Dinge
die man machen kann um das in den Griff
zu kriegen aber wichtig gerade für die
Patienten die ich sag mal in ihrem
denkleiden ihrer Denkleistung ihrem
Konzentrationsvermögen das damals zu
hören doch Leute das ist jetzt keine
Einbildung das habe ich wirklich
Herr Schubert Alzheimer durch Corona
also ich freue mich dass wir so langsam
uns annähern heute
und wenn sie sagen wir brauchen
interdisionäre Teams dann kommen wir
schon näher ich warne nur noch einmal
oder würde mich sehr freuen vielleicht
lasse es waren mal weg und komme mal in
die konstruktive Seite hinein und und
und vielleicht ist das wirklich die
große Chance das lonko wird dass die
Psychosomatik jetzt gesehen wird endlich
gesehen wird nach so vielen
Jahrhunderten innerhalb der Medizin dass
die Ganzheitsmedizin einen Aufschwung
bekommt für mich ist Corona ein Turbo in
unserer Gesellschaft in unserer Kultur
in unserer Ideologie in unserer falschen
Medizin Ideologie es hat unglaublich es
ist unglaublich viel falsch gelaufen den
letzten drei Jahren weil die Medizin so
ist wie sie ist und wir haben jetzt die
große Chance etwas zu verändern und
konnte das gerade angesprochen und ich
plädiere massivst ich bin auch den
interfusionären Teams etwas kritisch
gegenüber weil ich kenne die Macht der
Biomedizin ich kenne die Macht der
Schulmedizin und ich weiß wie Teil des
psychische dann wieder zum Epiphänomen
wird von körperliche Aktivität warum
wird Biomedizin von Schulmedizinern
eigentlich immer gesagt das ist quatsch
das bringt nichts das Medizin ist
Schulmedizin das ist für mich der
Begriff nein nein nein nein nein nein
nein nein das ist für mich der Begriff
Biomedizin und mir ist wichtig wie
gesagt also psychosomatisch an diese
Patienten Herangehen an die Geschichten
dieser Menschen wir wissen zum Beispiel
longkowitsch das ist doch ganz schön
viele gibt die schon Vorerkrankungen aus
dem psychischen Spektrum haben wir
wissen das von den posttraumatischen
Belastungsstörungen ja auch also sind
enorm viel Überlappungen zwischen diesen
Krankheitsbildern Corona hat gezeigt die
corona-pandemie das ist da ist das ist
da ist und wie gesagt also eine
posttraumatische Belastungsstörung zeigt
sich genauso wenn sie nicht durch ein
dezidiertes Trauma hervorgerufen wurde
aufpassen dann gibt es diese ganzen
schlaflosigkeiten und und Albträume und
und und wieder Erinnerungen an die
Traumatisierung in diesem Fall ist ein
diffuses Trauma es sind die ein Trauma
das durchaus von Politik und Medizin
gesetzt wurde in Angst und Panik an
Lauterbach hat nie aufgehört zu
traumatisieren und ich denke wir
brauchen uns nicht wundern wenn solche
Krankheiten dann Auftreten der Mensch
ist sensibel ist eine zarte eine zarte
Seele ja und wenn man auf der rumtrampe
drei Jahre lang so wie das jetzt
passiert ist dann wundere ich mich nicht
über diese postomatischen
Belastungsstörungen noch mal ich auch
das ist vielleicht da sind wir
vielleicht unterschiedlich hier aber ich
bin und setzt das hier hin ich mache
hier einen Punkt das ist für mich eine
PTSD das longcovid und es wird die
Zukunft zeigen es wird noch viel
Untersuchungen brauchen aber die
Überlappungen sind so deutlich und auch
Psyche macht was mit autoimmun wir
wissen dass Autoimmunerkrankungen je
mehr wir gucken desto mehr sehen wir das
Trauma ein großer Aspekt ist bei
Autoimmunerkrankungen wir kennen Burnout
hat auch ist auch ein stressostizierte
Erkrankung
somatoforme Störungen dieser ganze große
Bereich der wächst jetzt zusammen und
longkobiker für mich total dazu ich
würde gerne den Themenblock Corona für
heute abschließend noch einer Frage an
Sie Akkorde wenn Zuschauer das Gefühl
hat ich habe auch das Gefühl ich leide
unter longkowith wo kann man sich
hinwenden was kann man tun wie kann man
praktisch dagegen vorgehen oder sich
Hilfe holen entscheidend ist dass man
sich ärztlichen Rat holt dass man nicht
selber therapiert einige meinen sie
müssten Nahrungsergänzungsmittel nehmen
um das Immunsystem zu stärken und machen
sich gerade dann nicht so klar dass
Immunsystem zu unspezifisch zu stärken
ist gar nicht so ohne weiteres möglich
was man ja meint ist es besser
einzuregulieren also das wichtigste ist
eben hier mit Ärzten zusammen ihr eine
einen Weg zu finden was sind die
Symptome was sind die möglichen Ursachen
und auch eine Autoimmunerkrankung egal
wie sie ausgelöst wurde lässt sich
behandeln zum Teil auch mit kognitiven
Therapien aber eben auch mit
Medikamenten die versuchen das
Immunsystem wieder einzufangen oft auch
mit beiden also das sind keine
ausschließenden Verfahren die man hier
einsetzen sollte also wichtig ist sich
da oder sich eben zu informieren und zu
helfen und vor allen Dingen ist aber
auch wichtig und das gilt nicht nur für
die betroffen sind sondern es gilt auch
für den Bekanntenkreis diese Menschen
ernst zu nehmen in sie ihren Symptomen
egal worin die begründet sind dass man
sich das anhört dass man den mit Rat und
teils zur Seite Schild steht und wir
haben es eben gehört Menschen in
Gemeinschaften sind deutlich resilienter
sind deutlich widerstandsfähiger gegen
Einschläge im gesundheitlichen Bereich
also von daher Ihre Frage würde ich ein
bisschen unmünzen was kann der Einzelne
tun ich glaube wir können alle viel tun
und das heißt jetzt auch Gemeinschaften
wieder zu stärken Gemeinschaft wieder zu
stärken schönes Schlusswort zum
corona-block wir machen jetzt gleich
weiter nach einer kurzen Unterbrechung
mit Robert Habeck und Anna-Lena baerbock
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen meine Damen und
Herren zu viertel nach acht wir haben
viel Gesprächsstoff muss das wirklich
sein das ist doch völlig realitätsfers
vielleicht muss ich doch in die Politik
gehen ich möchte dass wir unser Land
nicht ruinieren
ich sag ehrlich gesagt ist das fast
totalitäre sie da vorne
in der kurzen Pause haben Herr Glööckler
und Herr Broder sich optisch ein
bisschen angepasst das Problem ist nicht
dass wir zu wenig Stadt haben wir haben
zu viel Staaten wenn die alle wegfallen
und wir uns gegenseitig in Berlin mit
der Cappuccinos verkaufen das
funktioniert nicht dann ist mit
Wohlstand aber das ist alles essen als
freiheitsliebender Mensch würde ich
sagen das muss jedem erlaubt sein
wenn ihr Opfer und umierungen von
Menschen in unserem Land fordert dann
müsst ihr bei euch anfangen da muss doch
was machbar ich finde aber diese gesamte
Debatte die wir auch fühlen auch ein
bisschen verrückt das ist nicht
aufgearbeitet und das müssen wir noch
machen und das ist leider Gottes auch
ein Punkt über den Bericht
[Musik]
wir sind zurück mit der These von Herrn
Kreis der Ökonom ist
ich bin jetzt seit 40 Jahren
passionierte Ökonom und was ich momentan
sehe habe ich noch nie gesehen ein hier
ziehen schwarze Wolken auf über
Deutschland führende Leute der der
Verband des sagen wir werden ein
wirtschaftsschrumpfung von 20 bis 30
Prozent sehen das nicht irgendwer
sondern der Chef von DIHK
der BDI-Präsident sagt die Substanz
unserer Industrie ist bedroht sowas habe
ich noch nicht gesehen 10% Inflation wir
haben in den letzten Jahren sehr viel
Geld gedruckt das sind Check geschrieben
worden Scheck geschrieben worden von
dieser Regierung die uns vorgemacht hat
das ist alles gut wir können das alles
irgendwie so wegbringen mit Geld
Regierung das stimmt überhaupt nicht die
Rechnung kommt jetzt in Form dieser
hohen Inflation und vor allem ist es ein
Frontalangriff auf unseren Mittelstand
die lockdowns haben den Mittelstand
schon dramatisch dramatisch gestört und
die jetzige Sanktionspolitik unsere
Regierung vor allem unsere Duo der
Grünen Spitzenpolitiker die mehr mehr
Sanktionen immer mehr
Antipathie gegen das russische Volk auch
schüren und diesen Krieg geradezu weiter
vorantreiben wollen das schadet und sind
ungemeine Maße diese Sanktionspolitik
kein Öl mehr von Russland von kein Gas
es ist sowas von absurd das Gas wandert
dann einmal um die Erde landet bei uns
als schmutziges Fracking Gas selbst als
untergrünen Gesichtspunkt ich war früher
selbst bei den Grünen und die
Umweltgeschichte unter
Umweltgesichtspunkten ungeheuerlich was
unsere grünen Duo an der Spitze macht
das ruiniert unseren Mittelstand und
manchmal kommen wir die beiden vor wie
Auftragskiller des deutschen
Mittelstandes ja die tun alles um das zu
schädigen zum Beispiel sagt Frau bärburg
diese diese dieses Nord Stream 2 Gas
würde ausschließlich dem System Russland
System Putin dienen das ist einfach die
Frau kann nicht bis 13 ja das hilft
unsere Mittelstand die haben jetzt im
Sommer mussten die sieben bis neun Mal
so hohe Gaspreise zahlen wie die
US-Konkurrenz das Überleben die nicht
lange nach dieser lockdown-politik die
wir hinter uns als ich sehe da ein
Frontalangriff auf unsere Mittelstand
und unsere Spitzenpolitiker Habig der
mit Inkompetenz glänzt das
ungeheuerlicher mag ein guter
Kinderbuchautor
kann nichts Robert habe kann nichts
auftragskills Mittelstandes aber sie
haben eben was ganz spannendes erwähnt
sie sind selber mal grüner gewesen sind
Sie damals schon wegen der
Wirtschaftspolitik ausgestiegen oder
hatte das einen anderen Grund Achim
wesentlich war das damals Claudia Roth
und die Bombardierung von Serbien wo
Fischer mitgemacht hat und ich wollte
mich nicht parteipolitisch bilden das
war binden und konnte mit vielen
Positionen da nie mitmachen ich bin
passioniert für Umwelt ich war früher
bei Greenpeace Aktivist und Umwelt ist
mir wichtig und was unsere grünpolitiker
momentan machen unter dem Label
energieschutz Ukrainisch ist ein
vollkommen absurd wir schlagen uns mit
diese Energiepolitik selber auf die Nase
es hilft dir Ukraine kein bisschen es
schadet Russland kein bisschen Gazprom
hat die
aber kein bisschen dass sie Sanktionen
kein bisschen Schaden das glaube ich
müssen sie revidieren es
selbstverständlich russland hat es 4%
4,2% wirtschaftsschrumpfung gehabt
selbstverständlich also es schade ich
habe jetzt Gazprom gasprimieren so viel
gewinnen muss
Sanktion ja schon Russland ans Land ja
alle in dem Kaufhaus GUM dieses
wundervolle Kaufhaus sein Moskau da
haben sie bis vor kurzem fast nur
westliche Produkte gesehen ja ich nehme
an dass der jetzt wieder heimische
Produktion kommt dann muss man auch mal
schauen wie das die russische Wirtschaft
jetzt
ankurbelt war jetzt plötzlich nationale
Ressourcen kommen also die Sanktionen
Schaden jedenfalls uns dramatisch sie
helfen der Ukraine überhaupt nichts wir
schießen uns ins Russland geschwächt
wird wird natürlich der Ukraine geholfen
ich sage nicht dass sie uns gar nicht
schade Sanktionen aber würden sie das
etwas differenziert vielleicht auch
sehen also Russland geschwächt der
russische Rubel ist heute sehr viel
stärk alles vor der Ukraine geht der
Euro ist gerade so eine schwach eine
Weichwährung gegenüber dem Rubel hat ein
Drittel abgewertet zum Rubel die
russischen Staatsanleihen sind nicht
gestiegen im Gegensatz zu den deutschen
Staatsanleihen die Währung ist stark
dass wir leiden und diesen Sanktionen
meiner Meinung nach ungleich stärker als
Russland vor allem wenn die ganzen
Gaspreiserhöhungen die
Energiepreiserhöhungen jetzt kommen
durch die Hintertür über diese
Dreiecksgeschäfte Russland verkauft sein
Gase dann doch über und das Öl über
Russland und dann machen wir den Diener
diese Heuchelei ja Abhängigkeit von
Russland und dann macht der Bärbel
Diener vor dem Scheich von Katar den
frauenleichte Menschen
wir Fragen hier einmal ganz kurz Herrn
brame das ist ja ein schwerer Vorwurf
wie sehen Sie das die Amerikaner sind
schlauer the business of America is
business also beiden hat ja auch Druck
gemacht wollte Putin wirklich die Stirn
bieten hat aber gemerkt dass er auch den
Diener muss er ist nach Riad gereist hat
ein Canossa Gang gemacht den man den er
eigentlich vor der Welt der
Öffentlichkeit als Paar Jahr Geißeln
wollte dann Kollegen von ihnen mit der
Kettensäge hat zerlegen lassen viel Blut
an den Händen hat Frauen und Kinder in
Jemen also den Mann hat er beknete mehr
oder weniger nicht drei Tage wie
seinerzeit Heinrich vor dem Papst aber
der künftige Hüter der heiligen Städten
in Mekka und Medina hat sich das
angesehen schöner fischbump und wie die
Washington Post sagte bei der kashoggi
damals noch geschrieben hat hat ihm den
Stinkefinger gezeigt also Mohammed bin
Salman hat nicht mehr Öl gefördert
sondern hat jetzt die OPEC Plus und
damit auch Russland dazu bewegt
zwei Millionen Fässer pro Tag vom Markt
zu nehmen also die Preise in den USA
sind gestiegen die Inflation ist
gestiegen und damit hat eben Bayerns
kurzsichtige Handlung nicht zum Regime
changem Moskau geführt sondern zu einem
Machtwechsel in Washington er hätte
diese Wahlen dank des abtreibungsurteil
sehr gut gewinnen können aber durch
seine kurzsichtige Politik hat er das
Wirtschaftsthema Inflation nach oben
geschoben und hat damit den
Republikanern geholfen diese
Abgeordnetenhaus vielleicht sogar den
Senat zu gewinnen damit dieser
handlungsunfähig also Trump ist im
Business und Mohammed in Salman liebt
Leute wie Trump genauso wie Putin und
wenn Trump wieder da ist dann werden die
Leute sehr viel netter behandeln wenn
die westliche Führungsmacht dann wieder
mit Autokraten schmust dann wird unsere
feministische Außenpolitik sich auch ein
bisschen
Außenpolitik das ist ja ein Stichwort wo
man direkt an Annalena baerbock denkt
was halten Sie denn von Annalena
baerbock als Ministerin ja sie machen
eine gute Figur aber nicht alles ist
durchdacht und ich muss den Schutz
nehmen auch erfahrene Männer wie beiden
der ihm sagt oh mein Gott ist man must
go wunderbare Rede Polen gehalten
Warschau aber zum Schluss rutscht ihm
wieder was raus geht er wieder ab vom
Skript und viele meinen jetzt macht der
regime change die New York Times hat ihn
gefragt was willst du denn eigentlich da
in dem Krieg oder Jim change Russland
Schwächen sowie dein
Verteidigungsminister
Schwanz nicht mit dem Hund wackelt wir
sind massiv abhängig von den USA und wir
haben kein Militär wenn ich sie daran
erinnern darf ich habe vor 30 Jahren
gedient und bei uns ist es wir halten
die Stellung bis richtiges Militär kommt
und seitdem haben wir die Bundeswehr
kaputt gespart und jetzt tun wir so als
ob wir kriegsentscheiden sind also grün
machen eigentlich ein ganz guten Job das
ist irrelevant für den Lauf Geschichte
was wir jetzt da sagen das was diesen
Konflikt entscheidet ist das was Amerika
macht und nicht sehen Amerika
abseitsbewegungen bereits unter beiden
da ist schon durchgestochen worden ja
jetzt kommt mal zu Potter wir haben
wichtigeres in Asien Stichwort Taiwan
und wenn jetzt die Republikaner des
Abgeordnetenhaus in der Hand haben da
wird der künftige Speaker Kevin mccarth
das Einlösen was er schon gesagt hat
keine Blankoschecks mehr für die Ukraine
also unsere Kernkompetenz ist nicht
Militär wir haben kein Militär unsere
Kernkompetenz ist Trümmer Männer und
Trümmerfrauen wir dürfen dann
Wiederaufbau finanzieren und da sind wir
dann einmal volkswirtschaftlich noch
mehr interpretuier in der Zwischenzeit
wandert die Industrie nach Amerika ab
weil es da günstigeres Gas und Öl gibt
und wir merken auch nicht und das wird
dann schon ein Statement nachher sein
das Bein der Kanal hat
unsere Wirtschaft
wie fühlen sie sich denn als Bürger
fühlen Sie sich gut regiert von den
Grünen nehmen Sie das wahr vielleicht
haben die Grünen auch einfach nur ein
Kommunikationsproblem aktuell das kann
natürlich auch ein Grund sein
das ist für mich eine schwierige Frage
ich bin bin ja sie fragen mich als
Bürger ja gut so und ich als
Wissenschaftler aber ich versuche dann
doch auch immer wieder so wie ich
Medizin sehe und wie ich in auch in den
letzten Jahren mich sehr beschäftigt
habe mit diesen ganzen Themen eine
gewisse Metaebene einzunehmen und und
die Metaebene ist Geld scheint wieder
mal ganz deutlich die Welt zu regieren
und zwar offensichtlich wichtiger zu
sein als der Mensch den Eindruck habe
ich ganz stark und das gibt Amerika vor
das gibt die die Grundhaltung die
kulturelle Grundhaltung vor ich bin
äußerst kritisch und und sehr sehr
skeptisch was da eigentlich mit Ukraine
und Russland los ist ich würde da gerne
auch eine gerne eine Ebene drüber gehen
und mir die Frage stellen was haben die
Amerikaner da wirklich vor um was geht's
hier und ich ich bin einfach Höch
skeptisch und und es wie ich sehe wie
gesagt diese Geschichten in der Medizin
ein einziges letztes Wort zu dem zu
dieser corona-geschichte es wird wieder
Geld verdient und wenn wir nicht jetzt
an den Menschen rangehen und wenn wir
jetzt nicht endlich aufhören das Geld
den Menschen überzustellen dann werden
wir wieder in Testungen enden wir werden
wieder die biochemischen Marker suchen
nach für longkowith und werden vergessen
dass es um Menschen geht die wir jetzt
in die Arme nehmen müssen mit denen wir
Beziehung haben müssen und wo wir nicht
anfangen wieder irgendwelche Cortison zu
spritzen und die Information runter zu
regulieren und wieder nur auf den Körper
abzuzählen und das macht Geld nebenbei
also die Medizin ist schon wieder dran
eine neue cash-code zu produzieren und
deswegen wenn ich das höre Amerika
Ukraine Russland ich denke mir die ganze
Zeit Mensch hört doch endlich einmal auf
und kommt zum Menschen zurück ich kann
es nur als Mediziner Psychologen
Psychotherapeut argumentieren wir
bleiben noch einmal außenpolitisch weil
wir haben halt schon über viele Themen
gesprochen aber über ein Thema noch
nicht und das ist China oder jetzt haben
sie uns ja nicht im weitesten Sinne den
these mitgebracht
China weniger eigentlich Amerika ich bin
kein China-Experte es geht um Amerika
warum die Auseinandersetzung zwischen
den USA und China und wir denken ja
immer noch dass wir der Nabel der Welt
sind wir Europäer es geht um uns und die
transatlantische Einigkeit scheint
wieder da zu sein nein Amerika hat sich
schon seit längerem abgedriftet nach
Asien die Hauptgefahr ist China und man
tut nur so viel wie nötig bei der
Ukraine um nicht wieder als schwach
dazustehen wie nach Afghanistan damit
die Alliierten in Asien wissen wir sind
für Euch da für euch Japaner für euch
Südkoreaner also man tut es Nötigste
nicht mehr um keine Kriegspartei zu
werden Russland ist geschwächt ein
seiner Schwächen bewusstes Russland kam
vielleicht dann auch wieder einen Deal
mit Amerika machen der dealmaker ist im
Petto Donald Trump die werden einen Deal
machen und dann haben wir uns genug
geschwächt und werden zusehen müssen
dass in Amerika weiterhin gilt
Paris dort wäre es nicht glaubt Mohammed
bin Salman er war am besten und jetzt
soll er wieder unser bestert sein weil
er hilft und genauso kann es mit Putin
und Trump gehen die zwei mögen sich ja
das heißt sie sagen Trump würde
schneller den Krieg beenden als beiden
die würden Deal machen Putin und dir da
habe ich keinen Zweifel aber Trump hat
ja ein wenig Probleme weil unsere Kosten
geht der dir nicht nur auf Kosten der
Ukraine
anzuerkennen das ist ja schon das
Problem ein Donald Trump muss man sagen
schlecht findet Demokratie
kann man Donald Trump überhaupt noch als
Staatsmann legitim ernst nehmen wenn man
auf die letzte Wahl schaut wenn man auf
der Sturm aufs Kapitol schaut ist es
nicht wirklich keine demokratischen
Werte mehr gut was wir jetzt dazu sagen
ist zweitrangig was die Amerikaner sehen
ist wichtiger weil das wird in den
zweiten Haus bringen oder auch nicht und
ich sage Ihnen werfen Sie eine Münze da
haben sie die Wahrscheinlichkeit da
kommt wieder der wird jetzt
abgeschrieben aber der ist noch
weiterhin voll im Schwung mein gerade
weil sie die ganzen Bereiche genannt
haben dann müsste ja jeder erwarten in
einer rationalen Welt wo es kognitiv
noch überall funktioniert müsste der
schon lange weg sein nein dieses Mal
sind bei den Kongresswahlen über die
Hälfte also über 300 Leute angetreten
Designer Lüge glauben dass der Präsident
nicht im Abend legitim ist absolut aber
man hat ja gedacht die Republikaner
holen noch mehr also es war jetzt ja
auch nicht dieser rutschart er hat das
gedacht also die die deutschen Medien
auch
wer von Amerika keine Ahnung hat hat
richtig die tiefrote Welle erwartet sie
haben das genauso erwartet wie es jetzt
schauen Sie was ich bei the pioneer zum
bisschen mattenwerbung wir gab aber
Steiger schauen Sie sich die Szenarien
an die vorgeschrieben
und da haben Sie das schon vorausgesagt
bei Herrn Stein das wahrscheinlichste
Szenario dargelegt dass wahrscheinlich
das Abgeordnetenhaus verloren geht und
durch Trumps 2017 im Senat eher eine
gemischte Bilanz haben wird und
wahrscheinlich für die Republikaner denn
Senat vergeigt Herr Kreis wer wäre denn
besser volkswirtschaftlich für
Deutschland Trump oder beiden Trump viel
besser Trump hat ja damals ein
Außenminister gehabt der hat sogar den
russischen Orden gehabt also Trump würde
relativ schnell glaube ich tatsächlich
versuchen zumindest den Krieg zu beenden
jeder Tag Krieg ist für uns jeder Tag
sein Sanktion ist für uns für uns im
Mittelstand eine Katastrophe die
Amerikaner profitieren gerade zu davon
ja sie haben ihr Fracking Gas ist
endlich absetzen können also ich glaube
rein ökonomisch Trump war mir nie
besonders sympathisch aber rein
ökonomisch wäre Trump sehr viel besser
wir bräuchten ganz dringend Frieden und
die beiden Administrationen habe ich den
eintragstut alles ein bisschen Frieden
zu verhindern für Protektionismus das
bedeutet der er will Amerika abschaffen
das ist ja für Deutschland eigentlich
nicht abschaffen
sie recht aber das ist mein Punkt
volkswirtschaftlichen er will ja eher
den Protektionismus als den freihand das
gibt sich nicht viel mit beiden die
beiden Administrationen halt gegen China
Sanktionen gemacht hat es gegen Europa
Sanktionen gemacht beziehungsweise
dieses 400 Milliarden Dollar Programm
das gibt sich nicht viel ich würde sogar
sagen der hat Beine hat gebellt nein
Trump hat gewählt und gebissen weil eben
mit seinem Narzissmus zu viel mit sich
selber zu tun hat der also beiden führt
jetzt effektiv die Trump jagenda fort
nur wir merken es noch nicht die
Franzosen haben es gemerkt unser
Wirtschaftsminister ist jetzt aufgewacht
und hat gemerkt dass es ein frontaler
griff auf unsere Wirtschaft ist jetzt
durch diesen Chip sein
Präsidenten Minister hat ja schon
gewarnt genau der hat gewarnt und jetzt
ist der deutsche Wirtschaftsminister
auch dahinter gekommen dass wir uns ein
bisschen besser aufstellen müssen aber
wir müssen das als Europäer machen denn
ich glaube das haben wir in Deutschland
noch nicht begriffen dass die Zeit der
Nationalismen vorbei sind dass wir uns
jetzt wirklich in diesem geoökonomischen
Wettbewerb wo Freihandel nicht mehr das
Ziel ist sondern Wirtschaft eine Waffe
für den geostrategischen Zweck das wird
dann nur als europäische Einheit als
Block in diesem mult Schokoladen Umwelt
bestehen können ich glaube da braucht es
vielleicht noch ein bisschen eine zweite
Amtszeit Trumps um endlich da mit ein
paar weiteren hinterschlägen auf den
Hinterkopf aufzubauen zum Ende der
Sendung noch eine ganz kurze Frage
stellen zu wie viel Prozent glauben Sie
denn persönlich weiß so Prognosen mag
man nicht gerne aber wie viel Prozent
liegt denn die Wahrscheinlichkeit dass
Trump noch mal zurückkommt von der
Amtszeit erstmal die Frage wird der
antreten vielleicht wird der nächsten
Dienstag noch nicht sich bekennen da
gibt es Frage hat jetzt Runde Santes
ganz guten Lauf der der super
abgeschnitten und Trumps Zeit ist
gemischt aber ich glaube da wird jetzt
zu sehr gehyped Runde Sand ist weiß dass
er ein Trump nicht vorbeikommt also wenn
der noch mal in den Ring geht und dann
wie gesagt ich habe sie dann schon
gesagt werfen Sie eine Münze aber es
gibt eben Sachen wie Corona wer hat denn
das auf dem Schirm wenn Corona nicht
gekommen wäre wäre Trump wiedergewählt
worden das hatte keiner auf dem Schirm
und das heißt es kann noch so viel
passieren in dieser Welt was wir alle
nicht sehen können aber unter diesen
jetzigen Umständen hat Trump sehr gute
Voraussetzungen noch mal in zwei Weiße
Haus zu kommen auch weil was viele
Medien nicht beachten derzeit auf
einzelstaatsebene Regeln gebogen werden
die nicht gebrochen werden können damit
das nächste mal rein aufgrund der
Sendezeit stoppen aber wenn man ihre
Ausführung noch mehr hören möchte sie
haben ja auch ein Buch geschrieben dass
von Herr Korte hat mir schon
eingeblendet wie heißt denn ihr Buch für
transatlantische
Illusion wenn wir meinen dass die
Amerikaner weiterhin für unsere
Sicherheit sorgen dann haben wir eine
große Illusion sie haben nämlich sehr
viel mehr mit sich selber zu tun und
wenn sie sich noch für die Welt
interessieren dann mehr für China für
die Wachstumsregion Asien und nicht das
Museum Europas
von ihnen will soll das Buch lesen und
ich wünsche Ihnen noch einen schönen
Abend wir sehen uns nächste Woche
Dienstag abend wieder tschüss machen sie
es gut
[Musik]